[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
what is up everybody
welcome welcome welcome welcome to the
live stream to the 3d live stream we're
doing it today thank you for joining me
everybody
it's good to see some familiar faces in
the house
what is going on
um yeah we're 3d modeling today we're
going to do a lot of 3d modeling today
on
the live stream all right i got like
three monitors let me switch over to
a monitor that works okay we're looking
nice
um what's up everybody yes
thank you for joining um
like i said we're gonna be doing some 3d
modeling for the infinite journeys
um 3d challenge we are two weeks into it
we got about two weeks left and as of
today there is a submission link so
we're gonna get through a little
announcements first um if you look in
the description of this video you're
gonna see
a submission link
that's where you're gonna go to
post your submission to submit your
submission to submit your art um
you can only submit one you can only
submit one so it better be the right one
just because there's a submission link
right now doesn't mean you have to
submit take the time as long as you post
on february 27th at 11 59 pm pst
you're good to go
it's california time for y'all so it's
like
if it hits
what monday for me
midnight
then it's too late so get it in 11 59
p.m pst uh yeah we got two weeks left
it's not too late to join the challenge
we still got some people joining the
challenge
uh so hop on in it's a good time it's a
good way to to learn and grow together
that's the whole point of all this where
you know it's what we're doing this is
learning and growing in the ways of 3d
um which is a lot of our passions we're
trying to tell some stories we're trying
to make some cool stuff so
every single week this month we're
popping off
and my cat is just like
going ham right now he's around he's
back there he's chilling back there
oh
hey
hey bud
he'll he's around um what else what else
we got we got a couple more
announcements so
um i am doing a rococo ama next thursday
i believe at let me get that time for
y'all there's a link in the description
as well there's an event plugged into
the discord server as well so you all
can't miss it but i'm doing that rococo
ama
from 2 12 to 1
i believe uh on thursday this upcoming
thursday the 17th there's a link in the
description click it ask all your
questions we'll get them in we're gonna
do a live ask me anything
with rococo so that'll be awesome if you
don't know
the full
motion capture performance bundle with
the gloves with the smartsuit pro 2
with the facial capture
all that stuff is going out to the first
place winner of the
infinite journeys
3d challenge
what that's one of many first place
prizes you're also going to camp mograph
this year um you're going to get wacom
tablets you're going to get looking
glass portraits you're going to get
mograph.com classes
and you're also going to get a max on
one annual subscription did i miss
anything i don't think i missed anything
if i did i'm terribly sorry
but the sponsors are also linked in the
description as well what else we got two
more announcements um i'm doing a puget
live stream as well on wednesday that's
gonna be the 16th from 1 to 2 p.m
um i'm getting together with the guys
over at puget i did a video with them uh
late last year we built out a computer
we talked about computer parts and we're
gonna be talking about computers on the
live stream this wednesday
the 16th
uh from 1 to 2 p.m we're talking
computers so come hang out
uh what else
yes so there is a work in progress
channel on the discord server the link
is also in the description it's at the
very top of the description
um that's where i'm going to be looking
at community submissions community works
in progress for infinite journeys so
we'll be taking a look at those halfway
through the stream
and i think that's everything i think
it's it's about time to to hop into it
so
i've been i've been working i've been
modeling
i've been doing some detail work on my
scene
and you're probably asking yourself
you're like clint that's it that's as
far as you've gotten like i'm so much
further than this well you know what
i wish i was further along as well
and that's the point of this stream is
we're gonna get further along together
um
so
here's what i'm doing
i basically let me show you my
references let me pull up my pref board
let me load up my references and i
basically have like a rocket car
you know something that's going to look
like this
something that might look like this
something that might
look
like
um this
you know like i have a few references
that i'm looking at i'm looking at race
cars i'm looking at mad max i'm looking
at some like interstellar and sunshine
and
star wars you know for cockpits and
whatnot
and i'm trying to build out a
like futuristic but also
mad max style so it's kind of like you
know like you'd see here in star wars or
maybe up here in sunshine
but it's like all janky and slapped
together
like this dirty and dusty grungy all
that good stuff
and i'm modeling based off of my
reference here
i'm looking at this um like toyota
race car
i don't know who knows why did i say
toyota i saw trd somewhere there that's
why i'm saying toyota um
so i've been looking at all this
reference i even got like a hummer you
know military style looking at hummers
anything anything little rocket cars
like this that's how i got the idea for
the fire extinguisher in there
and really it all comes down to the
reference
so i'm going to be detailing out this 3d
uh or this model here in 3d starting
with the seat and this is what i've been
working on recently is this
seat right here so
let me show y'all
i basically have this seat
ready to go here
get
there we go
um so i'm gonna be starting with this
i'm gonna be cranking on this thing
trying to get this good i'll plop it in
here and then i'll continue
3d modeling we're going to be modeling
for hours today so
thanks for joining me all
uh i got my steering wheel
you know this is just some like
subsurface not subsurface
words what are my words i'm having to
relearn c4d i'm gonna be honest with
y'all
um subdivision service yes
that's what it is that's how i made the
steering wheel it's how i'm making most
of this chair here and yeah you all see
what i'm doing here
um
i also worked in my framing and stuff my
roll cage with splines
so i got that going
um and we're gonna just detail this
thing out i'm excited to show you all
some stuff i've been working on here
like how to get this little weld marks
here little secrets and well not secrets
but
it's the best diet it's the best i can
do i'm working on it
um
you know my geometry
it ain't bad
but it could be better i don't know i'm
not a 3d modeler i'm going to tell you
that
we're going to go into that with uh
just knowing i'm not a 3d modeler okay
guys
we're all learning and growing together
um bit halo you know i really appreciate
that super chat you just did that's
really cool of you big fan inspired me
during the last couple years heck yeah
i went from teaching 3d
to 3d asset artist and now cg supervisor
of a tv series heck yeah dude that's
awesome amazing
super sick
tv supervisor cg supervisor for a tv
series that's awesome
you know there is some satisfying like
elements of that of like keeping a crew
together and making sure everyone's
working on the right shots and
everyone's organized and
um
that's a good time i guess that's more
of a coordinator supervisor would be
like on set right you're probably on set
making sure they shoot it right
but bit halo i appreciate it thank you
thank you for the super chat
all right
let's jump into it
i got the chat pulled up here taking a
look at
and i'm just gonna
continue where i left off i've been
trying to get two hours
in per day
that has been my goal and my challenge
for myself personally
um
i have a long way to go i'm gonna be
honest with y'all like two weeks
i hope i can do this in two weeks
i'm crunching i'm crunching just like
you are
okay
so i think i got the top of this chair
looking pretty good
um
[Music]
you know i probably could punch some
holes in
this guy
here let's do that let's do that
all right
the back and neck support all right i
got it symmetried up
all right
hitting q to go back and forth between
the subdivision surface
toggling it on and off
and like
the reason i say
like look at look at my uh
i don't know what you'd technically call
this
my geometry is janky that's what i'll
call it
um
you'll see what i mean here in a minute
so i want to punch some holes in this
thing i'm gonna do it the worst way you
could ever do it
uh but it works for what i'm trying to
do okay
so i'm gonna select that piece of
geometry hold control make a cylinder
t for scale
scale it down ooby what's going on
i know if y'all can hear my cat meowing
up a storm but
he's having a field day right now
um all right let's pull that cylinder
out
hold shift 90 degrees on it t for scale
get it down there
i just want to
kind of line it up from the
hippie top
there we go
and using the reference i'm just going
to cut some holes
let's see
so you can you can see them here we got
some holes going along this whole thing
and
i'm sure that's to keep this chair as
light as possible
actually i'm not sure i'm guessing
because because i don't do this um
but we're gonna do it we're gonna cut
some holes
in this chair to keep our render
as
i don't know who knows
uh
render peach thank you for the super
chat shout outs to you good stuff and
specs
in your render you only use the camera
is that okay
um as in you don't have a scene and it's
just i'm a little confused
in your render i only use the camera is
that okay
i don't understand
i would assume
did you modify everything except the
camera perhaps
tough to say without looking at your
thing as long as you're following the
rules then yeah
you're set
all right
so
what i want to do is basically
punch a bunch of holes in this thing
all right let's take a look at this
reference
kind of goes along
side of this
something like that
doing this in probably the absolute
worst way for some reason i think my
keyboard
is busted
i've had this keyboard
for as long as i can remember because
for some reason control drag is not
working
i have no idea
i can why control drag is not working
so i have to do this like a chump and
just
manually
good
yeah control just doesn't work for some
reason that's weird
take all of them
scoot them on over
goodness
what is going on
what is going on
uh okay
see why why does this why does cg have
to be so hard sometimes you know
okay i'll scoot them over i'm a group
i'm going to group them anyway
and i'ma put these guys
in
the cemetery as well
but i don't want them to be
subdivided
so let's
let's think about this real quick
boom fold that up
the polygon yep that's what i want to be
subdivided
that's what i want cool you gotta get my
folders right and then i want to boolean
this so
we want to take a minus b it's always a
minus b
so a will be our like
met bill big metal slab
b would be the cylinders
i'm going to do control alts
bool
and we will
create single object
and then i want to
bevel those edges
so what i'm gonna do
is we have the bowl in here
let's put the bevel
up in that folder
point one
and i'm just gonna scoot them out a
little bit so the geometry gets cleaned
up
works for me
works for me
it's certainly
not uh the cleanest thing in the world
but
it totally works especially from the
distance oh my god what is that
let's try that again
okay
all right as long as we don't have stuff
like that
we're good
let's shrink these guys down a little
bit
there we go much better
uh life with light thank you for the
super chat
um you know i'm trying i'm trying to do
a good job here
definitely as long if you can y'all can
learn from my mistakes then we're we're
winning so
doing my best so now that i have this
folder set up with all these little
cylinders in here i can just move these
okay now now it's working okay i can
just move these around and like
place these these holes where i want
and since we're in symmetry it's doing
it on the other side as well
so
i'm feeling pretty good about that
let's do
another hole based off of the
reference
we're gonna go over here
that works
i'm down
for that okay looking good so i'll be
doing that a lot
with this chair there's a ton of holes
in this thing
all right and you can see there's some
like weird artifacting here
i'll fix it if i need to get to it later
but for now i i think it's gonna be fine
and honestly i think it'll totally be
fine um
after the fact now this is not good
whatever that is
so let's see where that's coming from
i would assume this let's see let's just
start like turning these off
see where it's coming from
what is
it's the bevel
why is the bevel
doing that
it shouldn't be doing that
hmm
okay actually i think that fixed it
no
so you see this how it punches in here
you need to expand your clipping plane
so
i believe that is
shift
and what is it shift v
ah control d
control d
[Music]
and under project view clipping is set
to medium let's set it to small
and then you'll be able to get in there
so we just got a janky corner here um
[Music]
from the bevel
and for some reason
for some reason
we're getting a really harsh edge there
with the subdivision surface
and do i have something in here is that
why
no
it's probably just some garbage at a
modeling
i'm about to move on though because look
the seat is going to be viewed from here
like
i can't get every little piece here if i
focus on everything i'm not going to be
able to finish this
so
i'm moving on i will fix errors as i see
them in the final render
that's what i'm gonna do
okay
so i want to get the bottom part of this
obviously you can see here that there's
a flimsy little paper bucket
not looking good
and you know what hey someone said merge
points
let's try it
see if it works
all right ctrl a select everything we're
at 92 points if you don't see that in
your thing shift v go to hud on the
right and check total points boom and
you'll see it right there
i think uo is optimized we can optimize
it
and snap we optimized the crap out of
that that went from 92 points
to 88 points
that's great
that's optimized
basically gets rid of any doubled up
points or anything like that
cool
thank you
whoever said that
shout outs to uh
rinder
reinderprod
thank you
all right
so let's get the bottom of this chair
let's connect this piece here
to this chair down here
and then we'll add the padding like i
did here
i'll show you where i'm getting my
screws from
just downloading them for free
mcmaster carr that's the way to go
all right
so i have the shell of this thing
and snap hold on we got we got a super
chat from zeo tunes
a very generous super chat thank you
very much
mr zotunes zyotunes
um
it says hey should the horizon in the
shot be level
a character's in a boat i put a warble
animation on my ground
it's like moving with the waves um but i
don't want to mess up
the continuity with a rising and falling
horizon
um
i guess as long as it's not extreme it's
kind of that's up to your judgment
um
we're allowing camera shake
again to your discretion
so it's just up to you really really
it's up to you um
i'd say go for it like go for what you
want to make really just go for what you
want to make
check the rules make sure you're
following the rules
um
and feel free to post works in progress
you know we have
work in progress for the stream
channel in the discord so
i don't know maybe post it there
see what other people think
but to be honest without seeing it
without seeing how intense it is i can't
tell you um regardless though i really
appreciate that super chat it's very
kind of you
um your scene sounds awesome go for it
man
knock it out it sounds sweet
all
right so let's figure out where we want
to start here
now generally it just needs thickness
the chair
needs thickness and this obviously here
on the left you can see is the chair
without any sort of padding or seating
and this is what it would look like with
some seating i want to
have it look like this
i want to fill it with some stuff like
this
so once i get the shell of this thing
figured out
i can come back in and
and pat it up like this
okay
body frame symmetry just a plane a very
simple plane
all right i'm probably going to
move these points
to have this lip run around this thing
the entire time
[Music]
what's going on down
i got a little rat down here
all right
so i'm just using uh m o what is that
the
slide tool i guess
gooby what
are you hungry
i think he's just looking for some
attention
all right so it looks like this needs to
sit
pretty
square with this thing so i might try
and bring
let's grab all these points here and
here
and just rotate them up a little bit
and i'll grab these ones too
bring them out
as well as these
so
something like that
grab this and
move it over
[Music]
feels a little bit better
okay
and i want to keep this lip running to
down the bottom of this thing so
i'll make a cut there
and then i'm going to grab these edges
here
m-o
m-o what is that that's the slide tool
slide tool bam very useful for this
stuff i'll double-click this and it's
going to just select the entire run
we want to clone it all right so i'll
check the clone box and i'll just move
it out
like this
now we're getting
a little weird section here
that i'll need to figure out how to fix
in just a second
and i'm probably just gonna like
do that and do that i don't know if it's
the answer right now
connect that
remove these m n
is dissolve i believe
where are you dissolve m n
m
n dissolve boom get rid of those
we can slide this up
we don't want to clone it anymore we
just want to slide it
sweet
and i'm going to make some cuts
here
and there
and i'm going to select these edges
mn for dissolve
boom
sweet okay
looking decent
decent
they only need to look decent
because we got a lot of stuff to model
okay
all right
so i could be wrong
but i'm going to
go to polygon mode here
and ctrl a to select it all
d
for extrude
we want to create caps
and i'll push that out
let's try let's see what it looks like
subdivision okay so i'm gonna push out
just a touch
like that a little bit more like that
and then another touch so i'm just
working on those edge loops to
to thicken that up and then what i'm
going to do here is actually select
this whole seam this whole edge there
it goes around the whole thing
and i'm going to extrude that out
as well so i'm just going to hit d
extrude that out
and now we have like a little lip
running around this thing which is great
based off the reference it's looking
pretty darn close
nice little bucket seat there
cool
all right
now from here actually here's another
thing we can do and
i'm gonna do it
let's undo yeah let's go back to this
point because i don't want it to be as
thick i'mma let
these seams
be the thickness
be the thickness my friend
yes
yes
indeed don't know what that means
but i'm just saying it because it sounds
stupid
all right so we got some crunch town up
in here i don't know what's going on
here but you know what
part of me doesn't care
part of me
doesn't even care
because
we may not even see it
it's a little twisty i think that's why
does it help
not really
but it's chill because it's going to be
covered up by
padding and stuff
but don't even need to worry about it
let's connect
this piece
to the chair okay
so
let's grab the
shoulder piece here
i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna push it back
it's coming out a little far
that feels about right to me
now in the reference we have this little
like triangle support piece
that connects
this bracket the neck
rest
to the actual chair itself
so
i'll bust that out real quick
let's see
let's see if i can't use my existing one
because like we already we already have
one
i might as well see if i can if i can
get it to work
i need to dig gotta dig through these
these
things under support
all right perfect it's cloned already
which is nice helps us out
comes with the welding as well i like it
all right
it looks
like it's flipped
something like
this
this just is craziness
uh
yeah this feels right
all right
something like that and let's go ahead
and adjust the geometry on this
support
i'm going to even this out so i'm going
to select these points and
scale them in towards each other
holding shift bringing it to zero to
make sure everything is pretty aligned
just kind of resetting it
oh that's tight okay
let's maybe just
do it like this
that'll be fine
let's get the weld point which is just
the capsule
i have it as a capsule right so i can
move it
and i have a
displacer
on it
with some noise scaled down
with a low um
strength
and that gets me like a welded
basically like a little pretzel
but you throw some chrome on it and it
looks like it's welded put it in the
seams
so that's what i'm doing for that
and i'll probably bring the chair
towards this thing to square it off so
oh whoa what's going on here
all right cool cool glad i found that
going on inside here
i'm gonna do a little optimize control a
uo yeah we got rid of some stuff that's
good
and i just want to bring this part out
because i think that's what's stopping
it from squaring off
that's the extreme
let me turn on
soft selection
let's enable that
so more stuff comes along with it you
know
there we go
let me bring it right up to it
just like that
uh master wu asks if i'm gonna use
downloaded textures or make them myself
it's gonna be a mix
so a lot of this is gonna be surface
imperfections and just just colors
right so just an rgb value and surface
imperfections so i have my pack i'm
going to use all that stuff
um i'm going to grunge this thing out so
a lot of it will be custom
there will be some stuff that i'll
download of course yeah of course i'll
download some stuff but it's actually
not too bad to have it be custom so
and it honestly doesn't take as long
it'd take longer downloading all these
ones like i'll just make it you know
so that'll be for a later stream
probably next week
okay
let me
clean this thing up here
there we go
uh turn off soft selection
and then this this whole piece right
here gets welded to this like seam
up in here so we can bring
this stuff up
a little bit
this is again based off the reference
i'm just looking at this reference on my
other monitor
and it's telling me what to do
and that is indeed welded to
this thing so
let's go ahead and even out
these booleans here
helps to look at the geometry
see what's going on
i know some of y'all are screaming at me
right now
my geometry is just all
all over the place but you know what
i'm chill with it as long as it looks
good in the end you know that's all that
really matters for me at least
sweet and then i'll grab the
little capsule
this welding seam that we made
i'll control drag that up
get it right in there i'm gonna make it
editable
so i can
move some of these points and just kinda
this is when uh soft selection comes in
comes in handy so i'll grab all these
points on the end
right
i'll enable soft selection
and it will actually curve it
but i need to bring it down i need to
bring the value down so
you see how it's linear
so we change it from linear to like dome
or something
we want the opposite so we want bell
i believe
there you see it has the s curve
we can do that we can try that and just
rotate it
and that totally works
yeah that totally works
now you have a nice little weld point
it's fixed to the actual
side of this thing now it's clamped on
tight we have symmetry going on so we
have to do it twice
render collection of learning that's
what's up i love learning too
heck yeah
i'm glad you're here thanks for joining
everybody i really appreciate you all if
you guys are working on your infinite
journeys submission alongside me give me
a thumbs up
give me one of them thumbs ups if you
all are working alongside me
i appreciate you guys being here
yeah andrew k the soft selection man it
helps it helps man for sure it's good
stuff
just knowing what tools you have so you
can bust them out when needed
ooh
yokel
abductee
uh is getting a little ssd
on tuesday nice secondary ssd
uh if you didn't catch it i'm doing a
live stream on wednesday from one to two
with puget systems
the link is in the description i also
have an event plugged into uh the
discord server so definitely check that
out we're gonna be talking computers
uh and workflow and all that good stuff
hardware
yeah we got some thumbs ups people
working on their stuff the journey don't
end baby that's right kay
yes
then it's cool it's cool you're gonna
get that chemistry exam but i appreciate
you hanging out with us
we got a lot of people a lot of students
here studying got exams good luck to you
on your exams and whatnot
it's been a long time since i've had to
take any sort of test or exam
goodness
i i know and honestly i didn't really
have to do much of that either because i
didn't really go to college i i went to
a technical school for two years but
i ended up dropping out um
because freddie if you all know freddie
wong if you know of
our boy freddy he uh
he asked me to come out to la
and make stuff with them so i was like
yeah let's go
oleg where to find these blueprints what
blueprints are you talking about
the models i'm making oh the blueprints
i got you i got you i just googled them
just google
yeah i'm hitting up google and i'm just
finding
what i can find i didn't even type
blueprints it just came up but the way
i'm getting it in here is i'm hitting uh
what is it shift d or no sorry control d
no it's shift v that's confusing isn't
it shift v
if you can go to back you can load your
image in here
and then you can like set the
transparency and whatnot
and it's
very helpful for getting the right shape
of something
uh we got super chat
where are you at
say polar bears hey i remember you from
last week what's up
welcome back uh i still agree down to
save some polar bears
after learning the basics of blender
this past two weeks
sweet
he found there is no better feeling than
fixing a problem
without having to look it up yes yes
dude 100 it's the best like when you can
apply what you've learned to
your workflow without having to look it
up agreed man it's like you've locked it
in
and i remember when i was doing like
after effects tutorials with andrew
kramer
going through his stuff and he was like
yeah hit t for opacity you know um a for
anchor point uh s for scale p for
position usually it makes sense t for
opacity is like
you know you got to make it work for it
for you it's like opacity t for opacity
um
wait what would you say soto
transparency
t for transparency yeah totally totally
100 percent i got soto sort of monta in
my ear by the way he's uh he's always
helping out helping me make these
streams easier
so shout outs to you um
but um
yeah i just remember like going through
his tutorials and remember oh there's
this one effect and it was like a one
two three step thing and
i have to go back and watch it again
watch it again watch it again but when
you do it enough you remem you memorize
it
and then you've added it to your memory
banks
uploaded it feels good so congrats save
polar bears i i'm glad that you uh
that you're learning we got melanie
in the house it has been a long time
melanie let me see if i can do something
for you
he might run away okay but let me see if
i can do something for you one second
oh god
yeah
captured
okay
hey bud
hi bud
yeah he's hanging out this is gooby this
is gilbert
he's chilling can you say something you
want to say something
do you have anything to say
yeah what else do you have to say
i agree
bevel your edges you heard him
double your freaking edges
well gilbert says hello
good times melanie is it is good to see
you i was thinking about you the other
day um it's been a minute
i had the cats running around on the
stream and i was like snap
really it's been a minute
so thank you for the super chat i
appreciate that
uh
zhanco
jenko maybe i'm seeing it right thank
you
for that super chat is very kind of you
anybody else bite of way more than they
can chew bite off more they can chew
yes i bite off way more than i can chew
all the time
um
i think it is partly a good thing
because you're challenging yourself
but also if you're doing it constantly
and you're just running yourself
up a wall then yeah it's probably not
the healthiest thing
currently i'm biting off more than i can
chew with this render i feel like it's
just more than i can chew my mouth is
full and there's some food coming like
but i have a plate and i'm catching it
and i'm gonna eat that food that just
fell out of my mouth
later i don't know if that's the best
like analogy for that but y'all know
what i'm saying
appreciate the super chat though
let's get back to it
commander ford set 47 how did i make the
kill zone extraction film that's a good
question with a team of people with a
lot of good friends with a small budget
uh
with us a pyro technician
some costumes a location in a small town
in the middle of georgia
and
uh an idea
because i loved that game killzone was a
great game
so
yeah and then
ian hubert actually believe it or not
ian hubert did some effects for that i
didn't know how to incorporate 3d
objects into
live-action footage back then so i
reached out to ian hubert and i was like
dude would you be down to like throw in
some drop ships and some like robot
stuff he's like yeah dude i got you he
tracked it he freaking modeled it
animated it textured it sent me like the
png i dropped it in after effects and my
god is perfect
that was way back in the day
way way back in the day
all right back at it uh borknus thank
you for the super chat shout outs
extremely important question minecraft
or roblox
uh i'm gonna say 100 minecraft man
of course
came up on minecraft minecraft's the
best i remember the first time i played
minecraft
it was when i came to visit freddy
nico uh sam and brandon and jimmy and
like we were chilling out of their
you know
the the studio and uh
we played minecraft for a whole week me
and jimmy just dug an
upside down inverted like pyramid into
the ground
pretty sweet
all right anyway back to it back to it
i'm feeling good about this
i'm feeling good about this
about this all right well points let's
just throw in some weld points i'm
working my way down
this reference i got on my other monitor
here so
i'm gonna throw some weld points in here
um
this is the one that's cloned
all right
so let's
drag this guy down
it's a chunky world point
and i guess it's just like welding these
two bits together
it looks
it looks okay
we'll see how it looks with texture but
that's not bad for now
okay what else in our reference
i need to cut a hole
like down in this little hip area
i need to cut some holes up in here
and i need to
geomet geometrize geometize
i need to i need to angle this up
bad geometry
i see what happened
it happened up there too it's when we
beveled
let's be like let's do this let's do
this let's be like nah
get
go up and get
uh how many points we got selected ten
you oh okay cool cool cool we're good
okay
about that
delete
uh
turn off the symmetry to see what
is
actually going on
all right
you can delete
that
easiest way to do this
boom
delete
these need to be zeroed up
so i'll stack them together make sure
they're good to go and then
zero them down
boom
and now
we are set okay back to it back to it
let's get down here
oh god
oh no
all right we're gonna fix this
best way to fix
this edges
control drag
oh you know what okay okay okay this one
edge
ctrl drag
zero it
up zero it together
m b
is your bridge tool
i'm gonna just bridge this
bridge that
and then just make sure it's all
connected so
ctrl a to select it all you owe to
optimize yeah we're good to go
all right yeah that works that works
cool all right let's make some cuts
so we got this one triangle here i'm not
really sure
how to get rid of it
because i hadn't thought of it too hard
yet
i wonder if just getting rid of this
okay
um
yeah i don't know the answer to that
right now and i
i don't think i'm gonna worry about it
for this moment
danny thanks for the super chat am i
winning yeah i say i'm winning right now
i think so are you winning that's the
question
thanks for the super chat son
appreciate you
shoot okay what's going on here why
is it because there's some inside
business
i don't even know what's going on in
here
like being in the air ducks
i think it has to do with
um
peace
all right maybe
i just need to undo this
back to when i
it was normal yeah there we go okay
i think i just deleted something i
should have deleted
danny thank you again for the super chat
what is the outside environment going to
be so it's going to be like desert
um very windy some of like a wind sock
blowing wind
in the direction that the vehicle is
going to be traveling
um
probably sunset ish
i'd imagine
so yeah that's what i'm going for
md
is gonna be the
hatch tool
why is that man okay
um i wonder if i should just leave all
this open
that's technically the correct way to do
this
i think it's these like
these these caps inside that are
screwing it up
oh man
i really
really screwed this up
that was i made that mistake when i when
i extruded this in the beginning
and i added caps to
this little inside end thing
that works for me okay i'll just clean
this up now
at the top
oh what's going on here now this is
worse
okay
i think it's just now as bad as it used
to be
let's get rid of
the
world axis
all right i don't think i'm mad
anymore
i don't think
i'm too worried about this anymore
all right let's
get back to what we're trying to do i'm
trying to cut a hole out of this thing
i'm just going to brute force it
so let's do
a
cube
yes
scale it on there
with the reorder some stuff
because our cube looks like a sphere and
we don't want it to look like a sphere
so
let me think about this
we have
symmetry okay okay okay
let's go subdivision on that
pull that out delete the body frame okay
um
i want to group these together
because i'm going to do a bool
in here
all right
so the reference is basically
looking like um let's make this cube
editable
kl
or loop cut i'll make a cut
here
move it to the
66 percent mark
and we'll make a cut
here move it to the
33 mark
and then i will take
this
edge
here
delete it
rather let's delete these points let's
solo this first off
delete those
um
boom
that's janky
well you know we're gonna run with it
it's gonna be okay
that's the shape we need
um
let's go ahead and
bevel this thing
but i only need
was a ring selection you uh
you are was a ring selection
you be
i just need those bits
let's go ahead and set the selection
drop that in there yeah that's all i
need
okay so we want a minus b
bull object
very interesting
very interesting
okay
basically something like that
i'm gonna just delete the way
all right i don't need that
screw it i'm deleted all
like i said
not a 3d modeler
yeah something like that i'd say
and then we hit this with some symmetry
oh boy
let's try that again
we want this cube to have
symmetry
so let's get that anchor point
zeroed out
oh
yes
let's try it again
bull there we go
sweet okay
now we need to make a little liner that
goes in between
this thing that caps it off so let's
grab that cube
ctrl drag it to duplicate
turn off the bull for a second
turn off the symmetry for a second
and let's
let's solo it
and what i want to do is
make a cut down the middle
a one two situation
delete everything else i'm gonna i'm a
ul for loop selection
and then ui
to invert that selection with delete so
now we just have this like strip we got
a little run runner
here
and we want to take this and
probably put it in yeah subdivision
surface it already is
so we're good
but i don't want this to be
you know in the bowl so it's a separate
thing
it does need to be
symmetried up though so let's do that
cool
and i do want to hit it with a
subdivision surface
all right so now we want to match this
and kind of get it in there fit it in
there
so
let's do it without the subdivision
service for now
all right cool
put that in there
it's about like that
okay from here
let's see
i'll make some cuts
to match it up a little bit better
what why isn't that a being selected
[Music]
let's make a cut up here
tighten up this area
yep perfect same here
make some cuts to tighten up that area
and we probably need to cut
at least one
we can just
yeah match that up
yeah one there to match that up awesome
and we'll go one down here
sweet okay so now we have
this piece
on the inside of that we just need to
do some
extruding
so
let's go ahead and grab
all the edges here
move them out just a touch
do the same on this side
move them out just a touch
i'll make some cuts
on the inside
or you know i wonder if we even need
that cut
let's go ahead and just
make a polygon selection around this
whole thing
d for extrude create caps box is checked
and let's push it out
all right that's not working with the
bevel so i'm gonna delete the bevel
and
we're gonna just do this with the
subdivision surface so kl in edge mode
that's about close enough though
yep that's great
we'll do the same here
perfect
finally
that's about good enough i'd say
all right so now we're gonna go back in
polygon mode
d for extrude
let's solo it to see what the heck we're
doing
[Music]
wow that looks horrible
um what are we looking at what are we
working with let's um
go to point mode control a select
everything hit uo
to optimize it
[Music]
polygon mode extrude let's um
maybe flip these normals you are
so my question is why is it not
connecting here
i don't get that i don't get why it's
not connecting but these parts are
is it's because it's beyond oh is it the
angle the max angle
yeah
heck yeah
all right a little bit a lot and then a
little bit
that kind of gets us what we're going
for
yep
just about so i just need to form fit it
and i'll do that
with just one extrude like this
and we can form fit a lot easier with
one extrude
yeah about like
that just about like that
and the back as well
[Music]
it's pretty darn close
just needs to be a little thicker
spoop
thank you for the super chat my day's
doing going pretty well so far
get to work on my
my art here
hang out with y'all
i say it's a good day
i appreciate you asking thank you so
much
yeah there's probably going to be an
easier way to do this
but i think this works for me
i'll just bring this back piece in and
we're good
so
sweet
you know i
could work with
this
sweet okay
you know the sad part is
sad part is you know i'm gonna see that
oh
all right
ah
it's about time
that we
oh man that's rough okay
so i gotta work smart you know what i
gotta do i gotta work smart okay
yes
let's go ahead and take a look at all
the works and progress you all got so
far
um let's see here i'm on the discord
let's scroll up
i'm gonna do this for like
10 minutes or so
and let me get to the top of this thing
get all the way to the top of this thing
we're gonna go down we're gonna look at
everyone's work some progress there's a
there's so many
i only do this for 10 minutes i'm going
to set a 10 minute
timer
and then we're gonna get back to work
all right
boom
tim entire starts now
let's see what we got
okay okay
moving to the right that's good
probably want to focus a little bit more
on that window
let me full screen this yeah you
probably want to focus a little bit more
on this window space and block out the
uh
the left and right because that's going
to be that main cutting point is that
focal point on that window
michael what do you got
cool going with the train nice
sweet i dig it
maybe a little dark in the foreground
maybe see a little bit more light there
could help out
sweet
alright so i don't know
wow is that your
is that your previz you're doing
or is that just what it is
well regardless it's sweet and i can't
wait
to see this work out i love it man heck
yeah
i am electro good stuff
this one's awesome
i'm digging this one so far
let's see if i had any notes for this
like
uh
it's tough i don't give too many notes
because it's like well what if they win
it's like oh well then you gave them
notes and they won of course
i love it that's all i'll say is i love
it
keep it up
this one is crazy
i'm very excited to see what happens
with this one
i love the art style huge fan of this
art style
keep that up looking good tret
nalwa with some minecraft i dig it yeah
can't wait to see some animation in the
foreground
that's gonna look really nice i like
your lighting
very good stuff
hmm
oh snap
oh snap
that's great that's great i didn't break
through the glass or what does it just
open
are there people inside like come on
come on
dude that's so great i love it
i love it okay so this is your
your render here
um psychedelic apes yeah that was good
that was good we're on eloy now
got a little animation
sweet
robo and uh and a dude chilling on a
train
very cool
so this is the inside
of king cringe sons
a little animation here chilling on the
train a little futuristic city action
cool cool
nice
nice
what is this on the right is this the is
this hair on the right
it looks like a photo scan that's for
sure
i love your little mushroom plush thing
and these seats man these seats are
classic
i can feel them i can smell them
that's probably not a good thing but
the robo arm and everything
sick
wow this is nuts oh my god
whatever happened to this guy like
dang this dude
i'm so curious this is a very
interesting scene
very very
interesting i'd say um
it looks a little flat like between the
foreground and the background with
motion i'm sure it'll be fine
um but
vorzron
vortron
looking pretty sweet i love the
animation on this one peepin
p-pan
yeah this one's great
the subsurface on the skin is awesome
too your lighting's great i look forward
to seeing that
mondallo we got some star wars action
cool
good stuff good stuff working on the
animation
wow this is intense big old room with a
big old window
oh yeah i dig it i dig it i dig it look
at this little brain man up in here
sweet yeah you got some animation
turning the ship got the wrench sliding
around
that's cool
that's cool
land human
okay so it's a
j train
we got
kata hiroshima
i love your dangly little hand things
huge fan of that
very good stuff land human
iphone snick
whoa whoa
okay i kid you not
i did that to my friend jan the other
day i showed him to his house at 6 00
a.m we were going rock climbing and he's
he's got this game where he like
shoots you with a nerf a nerf gun every
time you meet with him
and i didn't have one on me so i had to
like i had to steal one from him so he
opened his door and i was hanging from
the rafters straight up swung in like
this dude
i didn't get him in the face but i
kicked his gun out of his hand that was
pretty sweet and i almost got him but he
ended up getting me
iphone snack good stuff good stuff we
got some trains let's see what else we
have uh this one looks cool though
big old train
b o train
sick
i dig it i love the uh graffiti on the
glass is a cool touch
helicopter perhaps train i don't know
oh my god look at that spider
nope
see what else i'm gonna keep scrubbing
down
uh this looks cool
yeah
yeah cool cool
i dig this
love the idea
train that just keeps going forever and
ever that's a solid idea
gala had
i'ma keep scrubbing i'm sorry if i pass
yours you know it's just
gonna get through a lot god dang this is
gonna be sick
afrin that's gonna be awesome
wow very very cool exterior
you worked hard on that exterior
yes jones lab i love it
what else do we got this looks kind of
sweet
wow
very scary
very very scary
i feel safe on this train though
actually
so that's pretty cool
all right here
paul oh my god
paulie
what is your name paulie van novsta
dude
that's so scary
are you serious
this is awesome
oh my god i feel so safe on this train
yo just straight up doing the hurdles
outside this window
the 100 meter hurdle race outside this
window
god terrifying i love it i'm gonna keep
going let's see what we can find
oh this is cool this is cool
yeah starting to mix it up i love it
y'all starting to mix it up
yes
yes
ooh we got a
sketch a little drawing here by scratch
it looks like the front of a car
interesting and you got the parallel uh
dimensions mountain or something that
back there
breath of the wild one of the two
this is what you're working on here
oh i see it's a train got you got you i
like that
i like that a lot
mr broccoli i'm down for some minecraft
100
speeding cube
nice little train action dig it looking
good
oh i like the colors here
wow
wow
wow that's good
that's good
great idea
solid idea harry 101 uk solid idea
um
oh i saw this one on twitter this is i'm
so excited for this one
this looks amazing
dom phil huber
yep this is gonna be sick
that's gonna be sick
uh evolver yo what's up evolver it's
been a long time thank you for the super
chat good to see ya
what is up
shout outs to evolver always holding it
down
on the streams
always stopping by good to see you man
oh this is cool some skyrim action
dig it
let's see yeah let's keep going down
until we see something that
catches my eye
wow this is cool
i like that it's a fun little little
spot i'm a sucker for silhouettes you
know
that's pretty sweet
astronaut chillin okay
a spooky ghost
curious to see what happens there
joshie art very curious
oh this looks cool
yeah i'm down for that
i like the beds the beds make it real
cozy that's a good touch
wow this is intense
i love it cd elise of course
we got some ghibli in there
this looks amazing ian good stuff the
beds man wow i didn't think about the
bed
what else do we have
this looks pretty sweet
metro yeah
yeah
that's gonna be cool wow
vazi that's gonna be that's gonna be
really sick it's looking great
wow we got a whole boat here
dang okay
interesting i can see the space here i
see your space for sure
i'm glad y'all are pushing it this far
though
because it's gonna really make these
montages really cool
it's good to see people doing that
yeah this is cool i like those colors
those are solid colors right there
yes i can't wait for this montage you
guys are killing it
yes yes apologies if i'm skipping yours
we can't get through them all
i will get to the bottom of the page
we're past 10 minutes but i'm gonna get
to the bottom of the page this is cool i
like the adventure
and that um
what is this
ooh those apples look nice
okay this almost looks like you're going
through an ocean
of wheat
this looks cool though i like like your
birds your colors are nice digging it
antics wow
pretty intense
super
teched out
what's going on here
wow that's cool
love it great idea
super cool idea bouncy hippo i love
those colors too and your lighting is
solid
oh this one this one's crazy
papaxo
crazy
i don't know if this is gonna be your
style like it looks like it's gonna be
your style it looks like you hand drew
this
this is gonna be insane
oh man
i can't wait to see this colored up and
everything
evolver i see a shout outs dude thank
you so much
the super chats holding it down gtc
spring with nvidia
and with my other company heck yeah dude
congrats good stuff
you missed the streams i miss you on the
streams dude
good times
yeah i can't wait to see that pepaxo
that's going to be insane
what else do we got
oh love these colors
also reminds me i'm playing this game
right now called sifu i'm a huge martial
arts fan
um
i mean i did martial arts for 10 years i
for again played all the martial arts
games growing up and sifu is so good and
there's a club
level that looks very much like this
and i can't wait to play
this game after the stream
what else do we got
again apologies if i'm going over yours
um
[Music]
there's just too many
oh we got paul
oh
oh dude i love this one
this is such a great idea
the drift the slo-mo drift
avoiding the cops
yes
yes i love it so much
killing it
paul you've been uh you've been doing
good work very good work and you've come
a long way you did um
alternate realities as well
and this is looking really good
zeus what do you got
yeah i remember this one
this is cool
i love the style and the design on that
feels very fresh
some underwater scenes some anime i'm
down for some anime let's see what we
got
heck yeah
i can't wait to see how that comes along
good stuff oh jack the hack y'all
remember his jailbreak scene let's see
how it come along all right so you work
the lighting a little bit
there's a horse and carriage there's a
wanted sign
i love the smile from this dude in the
middle right at the end he's like
got it
bullet holes
yes bullet holes up in this thing
it looks like bullet holes
oh that's going to be good jack i'm
excited whoa m design
[Music]
yep
i don't think i need to say anything
else
keep it up
get that rope dangling though i'll see
the rope i'll see this rope dangling a
little bit you know
these robes dangling
mushroom farmers man
mushroom farmers
oh this is gonna be insane
is this unreal
i can't tell if it's unreal engine or
what
but it looks incredible
oh what's this
oh
snap this idea
this idea
is such a good idea
wow
pablo
keep it up i want to see that done
that's so good
that's such a good idea
this looks sick
very nice let's see where that goes
interesting
interesting robo servant
on the train
very cool very very cool i like your
design here
very good design
i wish i could see the guy a little bit
more though
that's the only thing
wow your exterior is crazy too i love it
ah so good
anime vibes yup chillin
i love the anime vibes for sure i can't
wait to see all the anime ones
good stuff wolf
oh wow interesting yeah very similar
similar idea with the race car situation
tobias is looking cool uh i love mmm
i love this so much it's like the fort
you know have a little little secret
fort with a bed
ah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah the beds
that that's what i didn't expect
oh yeah
oh my god
look oh look at the expression
look at the expression like
captured the expression so well with the
eyes
wow
jeez
that's so cool oh my god
straight up like trinity oh my god
that's awesome
that's awesome that's awesome please
please keep that up
drip
dire grip fx yeah keep it up
ooh mitch mitch
oh snap
yeah
yeah dude
oh brutal those guys got wrecked
love me some pirates i'm down for some
pirates
and i love your depth of field i love
that it's
on the exterior yeah dude so good
mitch mitch
oh can't wait to see this dude
wow you're killing it with the
characters in the animation i
am no good at animation and it's good to
see
some incredible stuff like this and the
last one too
yeah
mitch mitch
holding it down
oh beautiful
beautiful this reminds me of like kiki's
delivery service
grandma's house
can't go wrong
this is beautiful
very beautiful
oblivion yeah solid stuff solid stuff
man can't wait to see the color
corrected
version of this
that's gonna look nice
oh i dig the art style
very creepy
very creepy
wow yeah
wow look at the mech in the background
it's like wolfenstein
awesome awesome awesome
very very cool
mdk
dude look at this skeleton
ah that's crazy dude this vibe is very
intense it's like uh what's his name
geiger that's all i know like from alien
forget the first name
oh man that's good
that's good mdk
and that's it
and that's it y'all
um
shoot
i can't wait to see
all of those finals
and that's just a taste we have
currently
4 800 artists working
on stuff now if this goes according to
how the last challenges go
we have a thousand less submissions
so we got 4 800 artists working right
now they got the green check mark
so we'll see oh
4808 right there just right there
um 4809 it's client 4810 it's climbing
don't just click it if you ain't gonna
work you know what i'm saying don't do
it don't just do it to click it
that means we'll have 3 800 submissions
which is coming up on just
yeah just under a thousand of double
what we had for our biggest one for
alternate realities so that's gonna be
sweet it's gonna be sweet
i'm gonna hop back into my uh
into my art
let's get back to it all right
oh god i remember
uh i did all that work for nothing
because i'm not even gonna see it
but you know what it's all good
i'm gonna throw this whole scene up on
the patreon later so you all have a
bucket seat
uh i need to focus on the rib protection
and up
i could probably just drop this in
and move on to like whatever's next let
me just check the rest of this
okay
we got some weld points
in here
[Music]
we have some like
back bracing
stuff but you don't even see the back
this is what you're going to see is this
so
let me punch
let me let me add the
the actual seat
cloth
and then we'll move on
okay so instead of like an over thing i
think what i'm gonna do is actually like
so you see how this wraps over the seat
i'm just gonna do
this
built into the seat
because this looks cool
so
let's do it
just cuz you know i'm gonna make some
textures or some
materials rather
let's go with like a dark gray
and let's go with a
chrome
chromed out we'll just go white for that
and then
i'll go with a red
because i like that red look it looks
pretty sweet so
all right let's drop drop this on there
black
red
white
red
wait
let me black out these screws
i think the original is up here
somewhere there we go
cool all right um
why am i modeling this
the lemon asks
um
because i don't want to just download a
bunch of stuff
for my submission
um
and so i can put it on my patreon too
that's why
because i get to learn how to model too
because i suck at modeling
gotta get better at modeling
i'm trying to model you know what i mean
i mean i mean
all right
i'm just being silly at this point okay
moving on
let's get some padding up in here
i'ma take this chair
i'mma grab the base
bits of this chair
okay yes yes yes
let's control drag this out so we just
duplicate it
all right and we're going to solo it
now we got the bucket seat
and we want to add
some padding to our bucket
seat alright so
let's make some cuts and stuff
all right um
i'll start with
these guys
let's start with these guys
okay
come on now
there we go
all right and let's grab a one two a
three
okay
let's also grab
i'm gonna just have that duplicated for
this for this little guy here
no i'm not
i'll grab it
also
would love some padding on the back
so let's grab let's just grab this
grab all of this
and
we want some of that booty padding
so i'm gonna grab one two three
just like that
and then you want your hips taken care
of
cool so i got all that selected right
i'm gonna hit u p
u p
that is to disconnect that's the hot key
for disconnect and the way i think of it
is we're breaking up
boom up breaking up
baseball up up
the dumber
your
phrasing is to remember your crap
the better
that way you'll remember it you know
what i mean
yo we got
709 people up in this
stream
much appreciate i thank you guys so much
for
for staying with me here
and modeling
we're crushing it today i feel good
i feel very good
oh how do you pronounce punisher it's
punisher
you know like
get pwned or get owned it's a gaming
thing right
that's a huge fan of pure ownage of that
show
there's a whole thing about
is it own or is it pwn or own like
technically it's the ownership
but
it's the punisher you know
so all right i'm gonna tell you all
story i can't believe i'm telling this
story
because i don't really like telling
stories about myself
but this one's funny i was air softing
at a uh you know i was airsofting with
sam and nico and dee like way back in
the day before we even filmed it for
node
and this little kid came up to me
they say
hey
are you the punisher
and i was like
you bet i'm the punisher
he was like wow
all right and he just walked off as some
random kid he must have been like
dude he must have been like
like
eight or seven or something i don't even
know
[Music]
and then
he went to join his friends
and they started talking and talking
and then i just heard from the group of
friends like we're all in the same room
getting gear like geared up for the next
match i just heard hey
that's the punisher you're talking to
and i was like what the heck
he was like telling his friend that or
something
i just thought that was funny
but he got the naming right actually the
kid got the naming right i didn't even i
didn't even realize it
okay okay okay
let's focus here
okay
what am i doing here
let's get set for success
um symmetry
yes
i think we can delete the chair
hmm okay okay
trying to figure out what's what i'm
getting a little confused on like
where my stuff is here
oh i deleted the wrong thing i think
there we go yeah okay so that's our
padding basically
and let's just make it look cool
um
let's hit it with some red
i need to see it better how do i see it
better um
i think there's a way to make it
transparent or something uh or i could
just scale it down
by five percent
and no i need to scale it back up by
five percent
that works for now
i want to like
get an edge on that
yeah that looks cool
and maybe an edge on that
and that so they're like kind of
geometric looking
i'm down
i like the geometric vibe
this one is a is a weird shape
so i'm going to change it
okay i'm down
let's tighten it up
i'm down for that i think i think just
that is fine
for the back support i definitely want
this well here's the thing you're not
gonna see it
and you're not gonna see this bottom
stuff either
so
i'm not even gonna worry about it
but it's here i might as well just do it
i changed my mind i'll curve it up
this one this is just for the patrons
i'll upload this at least you have a
little booty cushion
yeah that works
totally works
same for the butt
i think that's just fine you know
now i am confused on this situation
what's going on here
uo
optimize
um
the symmetry thing what's going on there
oh it's just going under the seat i see
i see
this one's for the patrons boom
there you go
let's make the back look cool though
cause
i don't want to you know all right so
let's remove that
let's
and this is just from reference i'm
going off the reference
boom
go in
like that okay
do a little cut
and a cut
and delete that
ah see
i wonder can that be deleted nope can't
delete that
let's just take this
edge
and
bring it up
and this guy can come down
just getting the shape right
time to weld
cool something like that
down
and the bottom piece is a bit simpler i
think
or maybe i'll find a way to make it
difficult
jay castro when did i start 3d um well
the first actual 3d program i started in
was cinema 4d release 10.
so that was 14 versions ago which is 14
years ago roughly
but before that
i
messed around with a free program called
wings 3d i don't know if wings 3d still
exists
but
it was like a free thing very simple and
i would just be in the library during
during lunch
with a couple friends we would just
spend time modeling so that was awesome
i dug that that was cool that's kind of
what got me into it and
i've always been down to creating things
but
yeah that was it and i would watch
tutorials there was bare there were like
zero c4d tutorials back then there were
so few c4d tutorials
that i that i was making c4d tutorials
back then
and if you look up
if you dig it up probably it'd be um
c4dtuts.com which turned to evonto or
something like that
c4dtest.com i did a
cinema 4d tutorial on like how to model
uh clank from the game ratcheting clank
and it was like a two-parter
and it's it's up there somewhere it's on
the internet somewhere
but um
that was way back
in the day it was a long time ago
but yeah i don't know i just modeling
modeling uh
hard surface objects like i'm doing
right now is
what i've always enjoyed you know
it's always been a blast for me
modeling organic things have always been
difficult so characters
gonna be tough
very tough
all right we're looking pretty good here
with um
with the padding
i'm just gonna make sure it's touching
the back of this seat and then i'll go
through and cut some holes for
uh for screws
and then
i think our chair is basically finished
looking good
all right let's take the symmetry of
scale it back up five percent
subdivision surface
we'll make some cuts
for our back piece
ooh come on now is it because i'm in
lolo mode
there we go okay
so chop that up
chop that up
tighten that up
it's pretty pretty uh geometric
though
this bottom piece is not
not ideal
that's what i'm going for anyway
cool
all right i'm gonna take everything
and
extrude it
just a little bit
create caps we can turn off so i screwed
it just a bit
create some more
and a little bit more
and let's make sure that
let's see
all this needs to be connected down the
middle
so let's just go ahead and
ensure that that's
all centered up
and
ctrl a select it all
uo
to optimize
ah maybe i
hm okay maybe the first one needs caps
maybe that's what it is
and then from here we don't create caps
do i smell in and out
i swear i smell in and out
oh and then we'll take those those uh
bits there extrude enter
cool
that's nice and clean
we can probably go not as sharp on it
too
so let's do
boom
extrude enter
there we go
and for the millionth time
i'll do this
bam zeroed up
and zeroed out
huh why is that not working
hmm
it's weird
goodness
i just need to make sure i have
everything selected
apologies y'all
there we go
what is going on down here
this has turned into more of a mess
just gonna leave it
looks fine
except for that obviously
all right
and i think i'm just going to leave it
without the screws
i think we can do it and just finally
move this thing
over so we have
this bit let's uh let's just clean
everything up a little bit
adding
port
this is the whole bucket seat
um
sweet okay we have a whole bucket seat
now that's great
let me just
yeah it's anchor point is that honestly
is fine
i'm gonna copy it
and let's bring it into our main project
transfer tool
oh my gizmo's hidden alt d
that's a sneaky one
yeah alt d will show and hide your gizmo
that'll confuse you
great okay
i can always add more detail later but
it feels good to me
junko
hey thank you for the super chat
awesome dude uh i have to turn in for
the night but love how yours is turning
out by the way the a in janco is
pronounced like mango
uh
jenko
mango a blender
learning mango
keep it up
thanks for hanging out with us much
appreciated
have a good night
and i'll see you next week
okay
oh so this is my camera that i
popped in here to like
to basically see
i don't know uh
there we go
what the driver would see
and this helped me place pieces more
strategically
i feel like his head would be a little
higher but it's okay
i got i got some moving around to do i
got some stuff to
to build out but
generally i'm like i'm pretty happy with
the layout here
i think i can go into detail on some of
these pieces
um i've already done it here for the
the windshield and like
the roll cage with the foam and
everything maybe this top console can be
built out
that'll be based off some reference
um let's figure out
what i want that to look like so
for paneling and controls i'm i'm going
between like these three images really
so this is very like
very old maybe 70s
80s
technology here in design
this is obviously like hyped up so i
want
something in between these
um
because i don't want the spaceship or
it's not a spaceship
i'm going for like a land speed
rocket car essentially to break the the
land speed record that's kind of what
i'm aiming for
so
going for more of a car is going to make
more sense but i still want to include
some realistic or not realistic but
futuristic elements to it i have this
image here
this is a real rocket car
which is cool because it utilizes this
like um
fighter jet cockpit kind of design
which you'll see
with these like slanted up
angled control panels
so i definitely have that in the mix
and
you know here's another reference
that's kind of similar to
this sunshine
vibe it's boxy and angled
but still detailed
right so i'm i'm thinking of that
and then i'll probably populate those
boxy angled
like foundations
with
stuff like
this
lots of gauges lots of readouts
switches
this is another good example
this kind of stuff here so
here's a close-up
i'm using shot deck it's a website
called shot deck to pull uh movie
screenshots
more close-ups
yeah this kind of like riveted boxy
paneling this is a render that someone
did which is pretty sweet
bolts yeah lots of bolts i think that's
what i need to
get this stuff locked down with a bunch
of bolts
so this is the real thing this is an
actual
race car so i'm kind of going less in
this direction now i've took it i've
taken
this in as far as a race car direction
i'd like to go and now it's time to
start leaning into the to the mad max
kind of look or the sunshine kind of
look more futuristic kind of style this
would be more in line with uh what i'm
talking about in the direction i want to
go
but i'd imagine all this stuff being
made from the same material
as as this because you want to keep the
weight
down as much as possible
you are trying to break the lane speed
record so
maybe it's made from this carbon fiber
style like this
not quite sure yet
or just this like cheap plastic housing
you know it's whatever your dashboard is
made from this is this looks like sheet
metal i kind of look like the look of
sheet metal a bit more so i might just
do that
i think this is really it right here
so that's the stuff i'm looking at
reference wise right
let's see if we can't build this out
a little bit to feel like that so i'm
gonna start with
this little like control control board
here
and let's first make sure my dimensions
are correct so
you're chilling in the chair
and that
fire extinguisher is going to be in your
way
i definitely need to get that out the
out the way there
or i need to scoot this over
is basically what i need to do is i need
to scoot this stuff over
all of it
to the right
which would mean i would need to bring
everything
all of this stuff
but i think i can do that after
um
i get some detail work in
okay
i want to keep this very simple
all right
okay so it's basically like just beveled
beveled cubes
very simple bevel down this
way here
so
ms
it's the bevel tool we want zero
subdivisions
something like that
and it looks like what they're doing
is let's see
bevel's on bevels here i'm just trying
to get the right shape of this
based off the reference
peace out
uh janko the man the mango
django the mango
heck yeah
thanks for stopping by
so i might undo some stuff you know
who knows
but that's okay
we have this i want to let's um let's
just actually make some cuts
i'll make a cut there i'll make a cut
there
and i want to keep this simple enough
that
i just use a bevel modifier for this
so i'll grab these little lanes here
d
or extrude and we'll extrude this
up
just a touch
awesome
and i don't even think we need the caps
perfect
something like that
see your render collection goodnight
have a good one
all right i'm gonna try something else
let's try
i want to get a specific look here
all right we're gonna get the bevel
go a little bit further
we're gonna make some cuts
we'll make two cuts
and we will
see
what's the best way to do this
two cuts
i want to open them
a little bit
i wish there's an easier way to do this
20 and
80.
i'll do one to see if it works
come up with it
and then i want to bevel do a secondary
bevel
let's do
a chomp
right there
control drag to push this back and in
and
let's grab these edges
i'm double clicking to
just select all that
all right that's close it comes
basically comes down and goes down i
already have it this is actually already
it
it's already the look
just with beveled edges so i'll hold
shift
add the bevel modifier
yeah just like that
really clean
and adjustable
so we're not
boxing ourselves in the corner here
but i like that shape there
so i think that's what i'll do for
the rest of this
okay
technically you're not going to see the
inside
so i can just focus on this one here
and i bet you there's an easy
way
to copy this over as opposed to having
to do it again
we could just do symmetry
but that would mean it's still there so
let's think about this
let's grab
these points control click polygon
to convert the selection
whoa okay
i'm gonna hit up to break it up move
this
section over
get it in place
roughly
i can even just uh
line it up
right when it disappears
there it is
perfect oh wait a second what is that
[Music]
sweet and then i'll delete
let's delete this geometry
delete all this
geometry boom
let's come back in and let's actually
connect these two pieces
so i'll select both of those
let me get the
bevel out of there
connect plus delete
drop the bevel back in
yep okay and then i'm just gonna bridge
these with m b
and we can
get rid of this edge
m n
to dissolve and then let's just grab
there ctrl drag over
and we're set
boom okay
we okay okay
now let's work on like the top paneling
so
i'll probably grab
both of these guys
and
let's extrude enter
[Music]
extrude enter again
and this is where our
command all of all the panels are gonna
are gonna live so here's my reference
jay castro i see ya this kind of stuff
right here boom
this is what i'm going for
so
it's just off on the other screen but
if you take a closer look you can
actually see these little rivets in here
which looks really nice
that's cool
so maybe i'll work that in that kind of
paneling
yeah that looks quite nice
all right
i think what i'll do is i'll probably
just copy this over to that side or you
know what
let's just do
symmetry
this can be a lot easier just to do some
symmetry
and the buttons can be
individual specific buttons so yeah let
me let me just set that up right down
the middle i'll make a cut
and get rid of these points
right here let's go ahead and uh
yep get that symmetry going okay
perfect
we'll make adjustments later but in the
meantime while we're building the bigger
stuff we'll
we'll work with symmetry
all right so this is kind of like our
our frame here
boom
and this guy
so we'll get that going but you know
what
i technically want to make some cuts
in here so
how do i want to do these little bits
here
so we'll do these little like
rivet cuts
kind of just making this up as i go
okay so
these guys are gonna be
there we go
what's the angle on that
sixty percent all right sixty percent so
we'll
scale these down by sixty percent
cool
sweet all right you guys will see what
i'm doing here in a second
if you haven't figured it out already
i'm just trying to make room for these
little like screw points
all right so
if this works
wow what on earth
how do things get so screwed up
what
that's ridiculous
who knows
who knows
right it's like i'm going for that um
oh it's from wait weird it's having the
bevel on that's what's doing it
there we go that's what i want
you know there's a bunch of different
ways to do this
i
maybe could have drawn it out
with a spline or something and done an
extrude
but this works for now
geometry maybe isn't the greatest
but again i can fix it if i need to
later
but i think that's pretty good
um
so that's where all the paneling and
stuff will be where all the different
i basically need to do that up here and
let's see if there's an easier way to do
this
so i'll start by
hitting
u p
on this and making it its own
its own object
i'll group those together i think this
is the better way to do it let's group
those together
so now it's just
you know
it's just free
doing its thing i'm not messing with the
geometry of the actual main layout i'll
maybe i'll go back and fix that but
already we're we're getting better at
this
so
solo it
and we'll bring it up just a touch
so we don't have that z fighting
some
make some cuts
all right
oh weird there's an extra
extra point in here
i think for when we
that's why gotcha okay
oh nice okay
holding l and clicking the polygon
will align the axis better i like that
very good
thank you
solid tip there
hmm
i wish it would
do both of them
okay let's see maybe there's an easier
way
so i could do that and i would just need
to make
some cuts in this thing
it's basically like a picture frame
i don't know why these cuts are looking
so strange now
[Music]
do
because there's no backing
why why why
why is this to be so janky
okay whatever it was it's fixed now
all right so i just need to make some
cuts here
i should just eyeball this
this would also be much easier if it was
flat
shoot
yeah it makes it nearly impossible
because it's flat
um okay let's see
this is horribly janky i'm sorry you'll
have to see this
hey
i'm just gonna copy this thing
get it up in here
oh you know what i should have done
before i did that
bolts bolts that's what i should have
done before i did that
let me show you where i'm getting bolts
from
it's a website
called
mcmaster car
this site right here
and you can go to screws and bolts
whichever one you want i think i pulled
this one
this one here and you can download
any number of models i think the the
default model always works download
and
you're pretty set basically what you'll
get is
little fbx you can shift drag fbx's into
your project file
and that'll merge it instead of opening
a new one
and i'm just going to transfer it
here and let's uh
take a look at our bolt that's a bolt
yep
and i'm just gonna delete
all the stuff we don't need to save on
poly count
all that stuff
and then i'm just going to go ahead and
make an instance of this thing
and just control drag
at every step of the way
sweet then we can
take all that group it
alt g
call this bolts
and
solid
looks good
and let's go ahead and
control drag that
and line it up
here as well that's what i'm saying is i
should have done this before
yeah there we go
these guys need to be moved
down a bit more as well
sweet now we need to get it into
symmetry so let's go ahead and just drop
those bolts
into the right folder
there we go
sweet
all right all right
ugh
all right let's lay down some more bolts
control drag this over
i'll scale it up because these ones are
a little larger
and i might go back later and
clean this up but for now
it's gonna be okay
i'll make an instance of it
and
do our thing
now if you want to get really
really
fancy with it you can go ahead and
rotate each and every one of these bolts
in a different orientation
but i'm good on that for right now again
i'll only do it
and take the time to do it
if i see it later
so
no need to waste the time
you all saw me waste enough time cutting
out the whole of this chair
feels like we even we even gonna see it
we do see it no there's a character
sitting there though so
you're not gonna see it
oh all right
what the heck what's going on here
let's see
why can't i not select this bolt
there we go
oh
okay
that makes no sense
there we go
all right
let me
do a thing real quick because it's
bright up in here isn't it
sweet hey
let's just turn it on auto auto iso
it'll be easier that way
okay
back in
all right let's save
c version now i still
go back and check updates and whatnot
save iterations
all right let's see if we can't
figure out
this top stuff here
i like the shape of it all
i'll probably angle it
toward
the pilot
all right let's solo that stuff
save the polar bears thank you for the
super chat you say you're off for the
day just wanted to say thanks
uh to myself and the moderators for
working hard so that everyone can do
these challenges and learn together
absolutely we appreciate you very much
we thank you for
for joining the challenge and for
learning and growing with us
it's always a good time i hope to see
you next week thank you for the support
and uh yeah i'll catch you
i'll catch you next week
polar bear
i have to figure out this contraption
here because
currently
steering wheel
is just blasting through the dash
[Music]
okay
i think once i finish the detail version
of this
or not the detailed detail but like the
uh
basically what i did for the other
stuff
i'll call it
okay
i like the shape of it
let's see if i just throw a bevel on it
already looks kind of nice
but i think i want to angle these
just a touch so
let's see what's the best way to do this
it's always the question what's the best
way to do this
um
so i basically take all this angle it
like that
but i don't want
yeah no that could that could work that
could work
so
yeah modeling is such a weak point for
me but it was what got me into 3d in the
first place
okay that's cool
and aq montages thank you
for the super chat
much appreciated
enjoy your sleepy time
get that rest it's very important
you say thank you for the awesome
challenges absolutely uh don't know if
you remember but you helped me grow as a
cg artist one time
that is very vague but maybe that's the
joke uh i appreciate yeah
and uh i'm glad that i can help out man
it's awesome my thanks for the super
chat and the support is
much much appreciated
have a good night sleep well
all right so these little guys are
basically
copies of this main one
so if i can get the main one looking
good
then we're going to be set um and i
don't want to inset it too much because
then we're not going to be able to see
like the die or the the paneling and
whatnot
but i might inset it just a little bit
i need a microphone i can see over my
goodness
all right let's see
i don't do this just in a little bit
back a touch
that looks pretty sweet i'm down for
that
um anything else i want to add
definitely some screws and stuff
all right where would the
screws and stuff go on this thing
and what would be on the side
of this
okay maybe like a
maybe
like
uh something like
something like that
just a little bit
like super subtle maybe
all right and then
actually or maybe
instead of that
maybe we do
let's try this
i don't know it's subtle it's very
subtle
not sure if it's necessary but it's some
added detail
it's not bad
actually that looks really cool
i'm down for that
yeah that actually looks that looks
pretty sweet
in fact
in fact i will do it once more
because i just got an idea from that so
let's try uh
another cut and then
i will extrude
everything
except for a little piece there
so it kind of looks like it's a
a console that is
held down
by uh like a like a bracket
it's like a little computer part inside
of a larger bracket
and then i'm going to angle them again
because i like that angle i thought that
was nice
all right
sweet okay
so let me add some screws and then i'll
duplicate this geometry around
jay castro i appreciate it
thank you
see i try i struggle i just struggle i
feel like i could i could be a lot
faster you know
all right let's get some of those
those bolts
jimmy james yo
thank you for the super chat
uh you say how long will it take to
watch 4 000 entries
what's the most important criteria
you'll be looking at are 2d animations
welcome
all right great questions let's uh let's
talk about it so
how long does it take me to watch 4000
entries well let's figure it out let's
do the math
um if we get 4000 entries
times each one's 5 seconds divided by 60
divided by 60.
five
five and a half hours
they'll take me to watch it all at once
it doesn't take me a long time
um but we're gonna do it
certainly certainly gonna do it
um
now what's the most important criteria
i'll be looking at
uh that's a good question it's a
combination of things so can you follow
the rules right did you follow the four
rules
that's the first thing
second thing is um
how great does it look is your
composition your textures your render
quality
your lighting
that all goes into how great does your
your render just look at
and then
the third and most important thing not
most important but the third criteria
is story like the idea itself oh is that
a great idea or oh did everyone just do
the same thing
that's pretty much those are the three
the three main ones
again
if your render looks good that there's a
number of things going to that like i
said lighting composition
your choice of color your textures your
models
um
you know
all that kind of stuff right that's very
pleasing to the eye and you knocked it
out
um and then yeah story and did you
follow the rules those are the things
i'm looking for i don't think i'm
missing anything
um
but that's mainly it yeah when i judge
these things
and do i accept 2d animations uh
absolutely yeah bring it on bring it on
if you can make it if you can still
follow the rules then you can do it so
good luck to you i'm excited for some 2d
animations i've seen one so
far um so that's gonna be sick
all right um
i'm gonna like i'm my mentally
i'm a little slow right now
so i can feel it i can feel the end of
the stream coming
but
um
i'm just gonna copy over yeah i'm just
let's let's let's finish this out
let's finish this out
all right this does bug me though i do i
do want to
see if i can't
well first let me finish
what i'm doing here
all right looking good
this is the thing i wanted to touch up
here
was to basically get
let's see if i can do this
or rather let me see if there's a better
way always a better way
yep
here we go
i should have included this in the first
extrude
there we go
and then
let's just grab this
wait what
there we go
um
it's probably a better way
phrase of the stream um
weld
i want to weld these two
there's the weld tool
mq
there we go
sweet
yeah that feels better
awesome awesome
it's not bad
and then maybe let's take this down
u y will grow your selection
that's how i'm getting uh
the outside what the heck
what just happened
what
okay interesting interesting
all right let's try that again um
you hit u and y that'll grow your
selection you can see whoop
gets that outside edge
and let's bring this back
and i want to slant it down so i'm going
to make a few cuts in here
and we'll grab those polygons on the
back and i'm going to uh
turn on
let's turn on
soft selection
what why is it doing that
like it has a keyframe or something
that's so strange
it it might just be my keyboard
because it's old it's very old
huh it's not connected
oh i see i see
ah
come on
there we go
that looks cool
all angled and sharp looking nice
oh
ah
i might call it right here
oh
yeah i get a little tired that's four
hours hey
i'm getting hungry too
all right y'all
i think that's it i think i'm gonna call
it
thank you all for stopping by good times
i'll see you next week i hope to have
this pretty much modeled
and done
i would like to get into texturing next
week
um
so that i can spend my final week oh my
god so i can spend my final week
building my character
animating my character
building my background
rendering everything oh that's gonna be
a lot in two weeks it's gonna be a lot
but hey i know we're all probably there
so
wish me luck i'll wish you luck
thank you all for for stopping by
once again we got some announcements
uh the submission link is live just
because we got a submission link does
not
mean you need to submit now
as long as you submit by february 27th
at 11 59 p.m
pacific standard time you're gonna be
set all right uh all of that info is in
the discord that link is also in the
description okay
um
what else i got a uh rococo ama with the
people over at rococo
that's going to be this thursday from 12
to 1 i believe
the link is also in the description get
your questions in i'm going to be
answering all your questions live it's
gonna be a good time and uh yeah if you
for all those of you who do not know
there is a full performance capture
bundle with uh the smart gloves smart
suit pro 2 face cap all that good stuff
for the grand prize for infinite
journeys among other things right
that's just one of the grand prizes
for first place
what else uh we have a puget systems
live stream as well so i did a video
last
late last year going over computer parts
and everything
and uh we're gonna be streaming for an
hour on wednesday this wednesday from
one to two
pacific standard time i believe as well
and we're gonna go over uh bunch of
hardware stuff go over computers we're
going to talk about computers for an
hour so join me for that those events
are
linked below they're also in the discord
server as well as as events and then
finally what else do we have do we have
anything else
yeah um get your works and progresses in
on the discord we got a special channel
just for that
thanks to the mods thanks to the
sponsors thanks to you guys for stopping
by and hanging out with me and one
watching me struggle and model
uh this thing but i feel good about my
progress i really do so
thank you everybody i will catch you
soon
and
until next week peace out y'all
[Music]
ten
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you